(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] You're hilarious, by the way,
and I love your eye makeup right now.
- Oh my, honey, I was on theme.
- I know, I'm just...
Yeah, but you look like you're ready...
No, like, rock and roll, ready for a show.
- I understood the assignment, honey.
(audience cheers)
I absolutely did.
- "I understood the assignment."
I love it!
So your new movie, it's
based on Chinese mythology.
- Yes.
- Yes, I love mythology in general.
I don't know a ton about
Chinese mythology so what-
- So, "The Tiger's Apprentice",
exclusively premiering on
Paramount Plus, February 2nd,
is this mystical adventure
of a young warrior
who kind of just goes on a wild wide
with the characters, the
Chinese zodiac animals.
Are you familiar with that?
- Is that like the year of...
- [Sherry] The year of.
- The Rat, the year of the Dog.
I'm the year of the Dog, I think.
- You are the year of the Dog.
I researched this, actually.
I was ready to go, but you already knew.
- Yes!
- I'm the year of the Snake, 1989.
- '82, baby.
Great album, there you go.
- I'm the Chinese Taylor Swift.
(audience laughs)
- That's what I was
thinking when you walked in.
- That's what everyone
thinks but no one, like,
talks about it enough.
- So weird.
- So, I play the Monkey in this film
and it's just so fun,
this star-studded cast
of Henry Golding, Sandra
Oh, Lucy Liu, Michelle Yeoh,
need I say more?
Bowen Yang, Leah Lewis, Brandon Soo Hoo,
he went to the same high school as me.
It's just like this...
It's a dream come true
It's a vision board moment, for sure.
Yeah.
- But you were also in radio?
I didn't know that.
- [Sherry] Yes.
- You have a great voice.
Even your "Yes."
- Yes.
Yes, it's like a-
- Well, how did you get into radio?
- So, you know, I wanted
to do it all, really.
- Which you can.
- Which we can, which we are.
- Yeah.
- And in college I did a
little bit of campus radio,
so after I graduated,
I got a job at 97.1 FM.
On the street team, that's
where you gotta start.
And cut to me starting
to do standup in 2016
and, like, making funny videos.
Carson Daly, who was the Morning Show host
at AMP Radio at the time,
caught wind of me and was like,
"Why are we not using her?"
So, he literally invites
me in to meet with me,
and he put me on the Morning Show.
You know, just do some
funny bits here and there,
and like, I always say that Carson Daly
gave me my first big break.
- Are you still in contact with him?
- I never got his phone number, you know?
- Hey, I am friends with Carson.
I think we should call him.
Can we call him now?
Let's call him.
(audience cheers)
Thanks, Brendan, yes, yes, yes.
Okay, wait, I'm gonna call him.
- [Sherry] Carson Daly!
- I love Carson, he's
one of my favorite people
I've ever worked with.
- [Sherry] I get lost in those blue eyes.
- There's Carson!
- What's up, Lil' Tasty?
- Oh my God!
(audience cheers)
Wait, oh my God.
- I have Sherry Cola here!
- What's up, Sherry?
How are ya'?
- Am I gonna cry?
- You should.
- Carson, I made it.
- Oh my gosh, of course you made it.
Look at you, Sherry, you're the best.
I'm so happy for all of your success.
This is the coolest story.
- What were your first impressions of me?
I have to know.
- Oh my gosh, I mean, you were
on my radio show years ago,
you did this character called Lil' Tasty.
I laughed so hard.
We always knew how talented you were,
so it's not a surprise that
you've made it big time!
- I tell everyone that Carson Daly
gave me my first big break.
- Well, I don't know about
that, Sherry, that's sweet,
but yeah, I'm psyched that I've gotten
to know you this long.
Well it looks like when I left your life,
things really started to
ramp up for you, so...
It's a good thing, I'm happy for you.
- Thank you so much for everything!
I'll see you soon.
- Alright, Sherry, keep up
the great work, thanks Kel.
- This would be funnest
crew at a bar, just saying.
At Barmageddon, there we go.
We could come on your show.
- Totally, you guys gotta come on.
Blake and I would love to
have you on Barmageddon.
- Let's black out together soon.
- I wanna play against Sherry next time,
I'll kick her ass, too.
(everyone laughs)
- Ooh, a threat.
- It's booked.
We'll have you guys on, thanks so much.
- Love you.
- Alright, love you, Carson, bye!
- Love you guys, congrats, Sherry!
Bye Kelly, bye everybody!
- Carson Daly, everybody!
I love him.
- I have goosebumps.
- And here's the thing, I don't do that.
I don't call people on a show ever,
but he's one of the
people that is like cool,
that you're like "Nah, nah,
he'll be, like, cool with it."
You know?
- I literally...
- [Kelly] He's so cool.
- I'm so grateful, that was so special.